Ngoài Nội dự kiến xe dựng thêm 12 cộv vượt xong hồng,
nâng tổng số cộv lên 2 tám,
có phần hoàn thiện mạng lưới sâu thông vàng đài,
và phát triển không dàn đủ thị thay bên sông.
Theo định hứng quy hoạch chung thủ đô đều trình đến năm 2019,
tâm dên năm 2019, ngoài các cầu hiện có,
bây câu đã hởi công xe dựng trong năm nay,
Hà Nội xe xe dựng bộ xong thêm 12 cộv vượt xong đường bộ,
trong cuộc vực chung tâm, nâng tổng số cộv qua xong hồng,
đoạn qua khu vực đủ thị trung tâm, lên thành 2 tám cầu.
Theo đó, xong hồng được sắc định sẽ trở thành chục xanh,
cạnh quan trung tâm và là biểu tượng phát triển của thủ đô.
Vì vậy thành phố sẽ tập trung quan lực yêu tiên đầu tư các cầu vượt xong,
nằm trên các bến đường vành đài,
để tạo ra một hệ thống đường vành đài hết kiến,
xanh sẽ lưu lượng xo thông.
Theo quy hoạch xấu thông vận tài thủ đô chức đó,
Hà Nội có mười tám kê cầu vượt xong hồng trong khu vực vành đe bốn.
Đến này đã có chính kê cầu hành thành và đăng khai thác gồm
lòng biên thang lòng chương dương, bính thuy một,
bính thuy hai, thành chỉ, bính thị, vấn lăng và nhật tân.
Bệ kê cầu vượt được khu vượt công sây dựng trong năm nay,
vồm tướng liên ngọc hồi, vấn phúc, mỹ sở, hồng hà,
thượng các và trên thân đạo.
Mười hai kê cầu chưa được sây dựng gồm,
cầu thăng lòng mới, cầu phủ suen đã có trong quy vành trước đây,
và các cầu mới được mùa xong vào quy vành như cầu liên chung,
cầu tâm sáng, cầu an dương, cầu ngọc thị,
cầu cửh khối, cầu bắt chẳng, cầu hình lương.